They're gone!
Every second, another earth dies
let's go go save the universe,
This threat brings the annihilation of all life
hope is the light that lifts us out of darkness
Oliver!
We might loose the planet, but we can still save the people
It's not time!
The Battle is lost!
Crisis On Infinite Earths
CW's crossover event begins Sunday
December 8th
welcome back everyone it's Charlie we
have the official crisis on Infinite earths trailer
we'll break it down
there's a whole bunch of Easter eggs
there's a new round of that flash ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be subscriber and leave your best theory
about how crisis ends on the video they
also released the official synopsis for
the first three episodes so we know when
certain people are showing up because I
know one of you are like when is Tom
Wellings Superman going to appear which
episode is he going to be in we have all
that information so starting with the
footage the trailer opens with the
footage from what seems like the first
episode I'm assuming it's going to be the
Supergirl episode and picks up right
after another earth has been wiped out
they cut the trailer in a really
misleading way so the order of the
scenes in the trailer is not the same as
the order that they happen in the actual
episodes so you have to assume that this
is happening somewhere during the first
episode it looks like they're in her
version of the de oh so I'm assuming
that either her earth doesn't get wiped
or they just watched another one get
wipe but it sounds like they have a
bunch of monitors tracking all that
stuff because they show you the crazy
graphics with different earths getting
wiped out they have that cool scene of
the two different berries talking to
each other you have Barry Allen Grant
Gustin from earth 1 and then the John
Wesley Shipp Barry Allen from Earth 90
talking to each other about one earth
per second being wiped out which adds up
to a crap-ton of earths meaning that
there's no way that we're actually going
to visit every single one of these they
get wiped a lot of them will probably
just watch get wiped out on a computer
board with crazy graphics most of the
mains assembling and the wreckage of
some building after a fight there's a
lot of footage from this wrecked
building in the outside streets so it
sounds like there's some big battle that
happens here it's not really clear who
else they're going to be fighting besides
the anti-monitor
because he's powerful enough to fight
them all by himself but he does have his
own minions and that might be where
reverse-flash
in because in the old version of Nora's
future newspaper last year there was a
passage that read that reverse-flash was
last seen during crisis leading an army
of shadow demons so even though they've
changed the timeline already they might
twist that a little bit and do a version
of that during the next couple of
episodes of crisis but like you look at
Sarah here she's clearly fighting
someone with her staff weapon and it's
probably not the anti-monitor they'll
probably address him really quickly too
you know you have three different
versions of Superman that are going to show
up during this at any given time if you
didn't know who the anti-monitor was and
you were new to comics you'd probably
just assume that they would fix all your
problems so Superman he's so powerful
you have three of them who can be three
versions of Superman the anti-monitor is
one of those people it's sort of like
the beginning of Avengers infinity war a
situation where you have Thanos beating
the crap out of Thor he did Heimdall
and Loki then beat the crap out of the
Hulk without his armor on or any weapons
just to show you how powerful he was so
that for the rest of infinity war an
Avengers endgame you knew that he was a
threat to the combined forces of the
Avengers so same thing probably going to
happen right at the beginning of crisis
so all the heroes know what a threat the
anti-monitor is most of them don't even
know that he exists yet they just know
that something dangerous is coming and
the monitor has not fully explained that
to them yet so everyone leave your
predictions if they're going to get rid of
someone at the beginning of crisis to
make the anti-monitor feel like a big
fan of level villain who do you think
that he's going to destroy because it
sounds like it might be this version of
Superman with the torn cape blowing in
the wind is right out of the death of
Superman comic right after he was destroyed
by doomsday it makes sense that they
would pay reference to that and use it
for a big beat-down moment to show how
badass the anti-monitor is then you see
a version of Batman's suit with cobwebs
all over it it's the same suit that
Batwoman wears so it's not clear if this
is on earth one orifices some other
earth but Kevin Conroy speaking of older
Batman did explain what's going on with
his version of Batman during the
crossover
he said the version of his character is
supposed to be way darker than Batman
Beyond old Bruce Wayne so that's
probably why they went for more of a
Kingdom Come angle with that special
harness that he wears like Kingdom Come
Batman if you've never read that
storyline the reason why that version of
Batman is different is because Bane and
a bunch of other super villains
eventually come and destroy Wayne Manor
and Bruce Wayne just retreats and starts
living out of the Batcave and because
his body has become so broken he has to
wear the harness but he's also become so
cynical that when Superman kingdom comes
Superman comes back to recruit him for a
new version of the Justice League that's
going to reform he agrees to help them out
but he refuses to join the new leak
that's how cynical he is he has this
army of mechanical Batman robots to
patrol the streets I don't know if
they're going to do Kingdom Come Easter
eggs if they're going to do Easter eggs for the Batman robots the CW doesn't really
have that much money so I'm not
expecting them to do it but it would be
pretty cool there's this giant structure
behind Superman and Supergirl that looks
way more advanced and different from the
architecture of the lobby that they're
all standing in and all this wreckage so
this might have something to do with the
monitors cosmic tuning forks from the
comics these devices that he's trying to
build that's part of the reason why he's
been sending Oliver in the arrow people
around collecting all this technology
speaking of which if you're wondering
why Mia is walking around all over the
place in these shots with Oliver it's
probably because the producers want to
put her in front of your face as much as
possible to hype up the spin-off show
that they're doing for arrow next year
then Sara shows up Lila is inside a
version of the de o on super girls earth
it's not clear if this is earth 38 but
the reason why the sky is red is because
the color of the antimatter wave
whenever it comes for a planet to wipe
it out it's red so maybe super girls
earth is right on the brink of getting
wiped out because she keeps talking
about losing the planet we can still
save people but the planet is lost then
we finally sees Smallville Superman Tom
Welling on his earth on his Kent farm
just doing chores he looks super
surprised to see who shows up
notice the correctly colored blue sky
behind him because pariah Welles in the
shot right after this is on a different
earth on another farm with a completely
different looking orange cast sky behind
him the reason why they do that on the
TV shows is to let you know when you go
to a different earth so whichever
version of Superman pariah Welles goes
to visit on his Kent farm it's a
different version it might wind up being
Kingdom comes Superman then everybody
goes to get black lightning in this very
dungeon II looking room which also has a
cosmic treadmill this might be somewhere
where earth 90 flash has been working
out of because there's all this really
advanced technology that does
look like something out of black
lightnings TV show and this treadmill is
exactly like the one the Barry ran on
the first couple of seasons on the flash
hopefully they'll finally turn the
regular just really souped up advanced
treadmill into the comic book cosmic
treadmill on the TV shows that would be
a really badass Barry gets thrashed
around if you freeze-frame this shot
funny Easter egg from behind the scenes
just the making of all this stuff
because they aren't finished with all
the effects you can see that this is
grant gustin's stunt double it's not
actually him in the costume then the
monitor seems like he finally explains
to them what's really going on the fate
of the entire multiverse we get our
first real footage of the John Kent
Superboy who's also going to be a
character on the Superman TV show next
year but their living room has a very
Kryptonian look about it it's also not
clear if this is just temporary or if
this will also show up on that Superman
TV show and this is where they'll live
then you have Kingdom comes Superman
laying some wisdom on them on the
Waverider
no sign of Ray Palmer in the background
I haven't seen any footage or pictures
or behind the scenes where you have Ray
Palmer and Kingdom Come superman brandon routh together on screen barry trying to
pull off a long jump high in the air
using the building to achieve takeoff
velocity the Waverider arriving and
flying over the city
then Supergirl talking about how they've
lost the earth but they can save a bunch
of other people and Oliver screaming
that it's not time yet so it's a bunch
of different scenes all put on top of
each other then they repeat the scene
where Barry watched himself die during
crisis really as him turning into pure
Speed Force energy just like Barry did
in the comic book crisis on Infinite
Earths but here's the full official
synopsis for the first three episodes so
episode one goes like this in
preparation for the impending crisis
with their worlds in imminent danger the
superheroes suit up for battle while
Martian Manhunter and Alex recruit Lena
Luthor to help them find a way to save
the people of Earth 38 then in episode 2
this is the one where Tom Welling shows
up the synopsis says the group uses Ray
Palmer's invention to track new recruits
to help save the universe which is
obviously where they find themselves on
Smallville's earth with Tom Welling
Superman the monitor sends iris Clark
and Lois in search of a mysterious
Kryptonian who probably is Tom Welling
Superman while Kate in car ahead to find
Bruce Wayne that's Kevin Conroy
version of Batman and in addition Mia
challenges Sarah
heatwave discovers a hidden talent and
Lex Luthor Jon Cryer's Lex Luthor
returns then episode 3 starts with
pariah Wells
and listing black lightnings helped to
stop the anti-monitor after earth 90
flash
John Wesley ships flash shares what he
learned from his battle in Elseworlds
last year with the help of Black
Lightning Barry Cisco and killer frost
come up with a plan that could save them
all while Oliver and Diggle return to an
old familiar stomping ground we'll get a
bunch more trailers after this so don't
worry I'll just break those down as they
release more footage next up is part 1
of the Flash's two-part Missy's and
finale so my video for that will post
real soon but everyone click here for
that new Rick and Morty season 4 episode
3 video and everyone click here for all
my other crisis on Infinite Earths
trailer and teaser videos thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome. I'll see you guys tonight!